λάάρχει ένα περιστατικό που ακομικού βαλά ο σταύρος που συνέύιστε να μην πουμε ούτε ονόματα
ούτε μαχαζί ναιιυπάρχει να περιστατικό το οποίο θυμάσει μέχρη σήμερα πάρ έουν πάρω π λλά
περιστατικά τα οποία στην πάρου στην τότε παρουσα φάσι με φόαυρικομοδία γίναν πολλά πράγματα και
αστεία πράγμα και και σοβαρά πράγματα α το πού μεκείνο που με φώβησε ήταν κάποια
στιγμή τραγουδώντας σε ένα μαγαζεί πολύ ωραίος στην αθήνα μπήκε να σε επιχειρηματίας ο οποίος
ήταν και λίγο νονός της νύχτα στης αποχής εκίνης τέγεισο το πρόγραμμα μου λέειαγα πάω
πάρα πολύ έλλα εδώ να ποιουμε και τις κούπες μας ι κούπες ήταν κάτιποτά που
περδεμένα με πίρα καιπότκα μαζί κιαι κατέβασε το και τα λιπά εγώ δεν επινά η
αλήθεια μου λέεα αφού δεν πίνεστα σου πάνω ένα στο πάρκι για να σου κάνω
το δώρο ταξε εγώ αχώθηκα λίγο η αλήθεια πάμε στο πάρκει να ίναγει το πόρπα
λέιδώρο οδικός τουλο δεν έχω ανάκη αυτά τα πράγματα ούτε απιλούμε ούτε καταρχει το βλέπου
και φοβάμε μου λέυπάρτο γιατί θα κάνο κλιγκ και δου λέω μα φοβάμε γα κάνει
κλίγκ δεν είχε μέσα σφέρα εννοείτα εγώ τα είδα για τα έζδισα όλα γίνει τη
στιγμή χαχαχάο και φύγαμε δεν το πύρα αποτέτο όπλο αραέζει στιγμές περίεργες σε αυτή τηπορεία
των πεντεκάξι μου φαινότου α λίγο περίεργα γιατί μένα στοτοινατανε απλά ότι να τραγουδάμε να
περνάμα ωραία υπάρχουν όμως και αυτά υπάρχουν κι ταν αρκωτικά μέσα στη νύχτα υπάρχουν πισόπλα
τες μας ηκυρίίες υπάρχουν πάρα πολλά καύ αστεία όμως βεβαίως γίναται γιατί κάποια στιγμήσει τη
θεσαλονίκη ιουτότε που στο παιχνίδι είχε γίνει λίγοαγαπισιάρικοτραγούδι απότή μεριά μου τόσι λέωυπήρχει ένα καλώ
διο κάτω πως όπα επειδής κόντα ψάλεότε